it's time for takeoff but not like
you've ever seen it before
charged up and ready to go the uk's
first ever fully electric training plane
flight school involved hope that by
cutting down carbon and noise this could
be a huge leap for sustainable air
travel the future is is going electric
and going green and so you know this is
the first step towards a training
aircraft and it's important that people
learn to fly with this and this is going
to be the new technology so it's a
conventional aircraft so we have a
central control stick here sam has flown
for more than 30 years and after more
than 16 000 air miles he's never had an
hour in the sky like that one
but there will be challenges
the charging infrastructure like it is
with with cars you know has to be grown
to make it a sustainable thing electric
flights like these are meant to be the
future they're cleaner quieter and
eventually they'll be able to go further
too in the race to jet zero commercial
airliners are also exploring similar
options
that change will take some time though
30 years away until we till we do we
finish this thing properly
and engineers like me we've got a
mountains climb to make it happen and i
can't wait to trade up to electricity
we've got a lot of work to do and it's
something that we can and must do as
well
it might be a while until electric
planes take off everywhere but here that
idea has already arrived shinki marike
sky news blackbush airport